let's talk about netflix
so anything with things like netflix
amazon prime any of these video
streaming services
so i'm not limiting this just to netflix
but anything that's a video streaming
service
you'll start to notice once you take the
red pill and you get familiar with
you know paying attention to female
nature and behavior
uh and you use this lens to observe the
world in a slightly different way than
what you've seen it your entire life
that most modern shows facilitate
the worshipping and pedestalization of a
female primary social order
let me give you a really good example we
had this discussion the other day
on a post in my men's forum
charlie's angels um i wish i could pull
it up and
show you the highlight reel clip but
just go to youtube and search for it but
it's basically a man-hating movie it's a
movie about
three women uh that really just don't
like men and are trying to compete
against them all the time
and put and it's it's really just
shaming that now
that's nothing new this this has been
going on for a while i can go back and i
can
recall um what was that show tim the two
mill
tim the tool man taylor uh home
improvement
i remember watching that in my teens or
even twenties i can't remember when it
was but quite
quite a while ago so let's say 20 years
ago the father the
you know the man that was the head of
the household has
always been portrayed ever since i was a
kid
with the exception of some shows like
you go back to dukes of hazard
knight rider stuff like that where
masculinity was still you know men were
still men sort of
sort of thing um shows after that
that that followed that after the 80s
and 90s
almost all of these shows facilitate
female worship
pedestalization of women the father the
men are bumbling idiots
if i turn on any show like if i want to
kick back and relax
and go and watch something on netflix
i'm always asking myself as i'm
consuming this within the first 15
minutes or so
is this some man-hating crap does this
facilitate a
worship of women you know sort of thing
because if you want to feed your mind
with positive masculine ideas and become
a better version of yourself and level
up in life
you need to remove negative influences
from your life
you